bonjour à tous bienvenue seule chaîne
parlementaire c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo on refait l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec catherine gilbert
bonjour kadia et cette semaine dans
l'actualité un premier ministre qui
occupe tous les terrains lundi quelques
heures aux banlieues et puis s'en va
manuel valls et 17 min sont allés aux
mureaux dans les yvelines comité
interministériel le premier ministre a
promis d'agir pour ses quartiers manuel
valls à la tâte également sur le front
politique tout devra être fait pour
empêcher le front national de gagner une
région lors des élections régionales
parole du premier ministre au micro du
bondy blog des paroles dont on a
beaucoup parlé
et puis nous parlerons du sénat qui
refuse de ratifier la charte sur les
langues régionales attaques de la gauche
qui parle de faute et de vision
rabougrie tout un programme
et cette semaine de niveaux pas et notre
invité bonjour vous êtes député
écologiste de paris et vice-président de
l'assemblée nationale il ya beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous cette semaine
n'est c'est la coutume pour commencer
cette émission on a demandé à vos
collègues
ce qu'il pensait de vous écouter c'est
un écologiste qui suis un pragmatique
pour pouvoir
cherchez les avancées partout où elles
se trouvent où je trouve sympathique
bah c'est déjà bien il est pugnace par
exemple sur nucléaire quelqu'un de très
obstiné
quand on est un écologiste vaut mieux
être obstiné tenace et persévérant il
est très travailleur
flegmatique obsédé par l'écologie
virtuel à laquelle il croit et
déconnectée des réalités terrain dans
lesquels on vit tous les jours plutôt
courtois a assez assez en rondeur ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas
d'autres élus de son mouvement denis
baupin reste une passerelle est une des
dernières passerelle entre europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste
j'espère qu'il va continuer à penser que
l'écologie politique c'est la seule
façon de transformer la société
alors réaction et surtout vous continué
à porter ce combat et notamment au sein
d'europe écologie les verts
on reste je suis écologiste un réel jeu
pacherie là deux pignons ça fait
vingt-cinq à moi je suis assez
pragmatique sur les questions des
boutiques les boutiques et son service
justement du combat 1 c'est à dire que
la question c'est des convictions et
quelle quelle conviction et comment on
les portait donc que ce que je constate
dans notre histoire
27 ans que je suis membre des verts
c'est que chaque fois que les verts
n'ont pas su occuper correctement leur
espace politique et s'est créé quelque
chose à côté il y avait génération
écologie
l'élu europe ecologie il ya aujourd'hui
maintenant écologistes et élus des yeux
parce que on n'occupe pas correctement
notre espace pourquoi on n'occupe pas
correctement notre espace c'est que on
il ya une décision qui a été prise de
sortir du gouvernement alors même qu'on
avait fait lire françois hollande
puisqu'on avait appelé à voter pour lui
au second tour pour ça que nous mêmes
parlementaires on a été on a été élu en
alliance avec les socialistes donc je
pense que notre responsabilité c'est
d'être dans l'exécutif c'est pas facile
dans l'exécutif met donc mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui je suis élevé parce qu'on
est dans une campagne pour les élections
régionales et j'attends de voir comment
comment élever tirera les enseignements
de cette campagne veut guérir le
dernièrement que pendant la campagne des
régionales vous ne partirez pas d'europe
écologie les verts mais qu' après vous
pourriez décider de partir j'attends de
mon parti qu'ils comprennent ce qui est
en train de se passer
que des gens soient partis étaient
responsables de président de groupe
sont partis sur des désaccords comme
cela ça dit quelque chose d'une absence
de débat à l'intérieur
est ce que notre parti politique est
capable de comprendre ce qui est en
train de se passer comme ça c'est fait
justement quand je raconte génération
écologie on nous dit que tout est aussi
d'après enfin si si demain on me dit oh
ben marine le pen a été élue présidente
de région par exemple pendant un
scénario celui là on n'a rien fait pour
vraiment l'empêché pas ce qu'il y'a eu
division des listes au premier tour
alors mais qu'on s'en fiche il ya un
moment où de partir et j'en sais rien je
ne veux pas vous dire je ne lis pas dans
le marc de café
je préfère me positionner comme
quelqu'un qui influence mais je sais pas
je suis pas non plus pieds et poings
liés à des décisions qui seraient prises
par d'autres avec lesquels je ne
pourrais pas adhérer pour moi le front
national c'est un sujet grave
elle revend repart national est aux
portes du pouvoir on ne peut pas
simplement continuer à faire la petite
tambouille comme d'habitude il ya un
moment où il faut se dire qu'est ce
qu'on est qu'est ce qu'on fait nous en
termes de réseaux d'élus républicains
d'élus écologistes pour faire en sorte
que l'on laisse pas les manettes à des
gens qui vont faire vraiment rien
écologistes vous aurez le temps
évidemment de développer tout cela on va
commencer par le lundi manuel valls fait
un petit tour en banlieue nous sommes
dix ans après les émeutes de clichy sous
bois le premier ministre accompagné de
17 membres du gouvernement s'est voulu
offensif en particulier sur le terrain
de la discrimination monsieur des
annonces sur le logement on voit tout
cela avec jean baptiste daoulas manuel
valls en visite avec 17 ministres un
déplacement en forme d'opérations de
communication
dix ans après les émeutes de clichy sous
bois mais le premier ministre refuse de
parler d'une reconquête des banlieues ne
tue pas à la reconquête je suis là pour
faire le point sur la mise en oeuvre des
choix que nous avons annoncé au début de
l'année
au programme une visite d'un
commissariat en construction et d'un
quartier réhabiliter ce qui est
important
savait aussi mec moi c'est pas
uniquement la démolition du tout
derrière l'aménagement est compris de ce
qui reste le premier ministre est venu
avec des mesures pour les banlieues les
forces de l'ordre seront équipés de
caméras sur le terrain pour lutter
contre les discriminations et protéger
les officiers lutte contre les
discriminations également avec des
opérations de testing fin 2015 dans le
monde du travail pour éviter les
inégalités al embauche
enfin les villes qui refusent
d'appliquer la loi sur les logements
sociaux sont dans le collimateur du
gouvernement
quand une loi de la république n'est pas
appliquée pour lamy cité
eh bien il faut dénoncer ce qui ne
l'appliquent pas cette loi et faire en
sorte que la loi s'applique tout
simplement dans les trente civils mise
en cause par le gouvernement les préfets
géreront directement à la construction
de logements sociaux un ensemble de
mesures pour lutter contre ce que manuel
valls appelle un apartheid dans les
banlieues
denis baupin il ya un certain nombre
d'annoncés faites par le prémunit yann
il contrôle au faciès et annie le droit
de vote pour les étrangers 7
deux promesses de françois hollande
pendant sa campagne présidentielle
est ce que ce sont des choses que vous
regrettez aujourd'hui d'abord dire que y
assemble annonces qui sont importantes
et que la question des banlieues je
trouvais est insuffisamment présente
aujourd'hui dans la campagne des
élections régionales
dire que quand on parle de la région on
a une région qui a beaucoup de
déséquilibre très important vous avez
des départements très riches comme les
hauts-de-seine où paris et puis d'autres
qui sont beaucoup plus défavorisés et
que le rééquilibrage entre les deux
c'est un point important
deuxième constat ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui sur ces mères délinquants
qui ne font pas construire des
suffisamment de logements sociaux c'est
important aussi je constate d'ailleurs
que ces mères sont les premiers à dire
qu'il faut la tolérance zéro dans les
banlieues mais qui sont des maires de
banlieue ou que les agences qui est que
ce sont des délinquants sexuels
oui mais nous on dort on n'a pas
appliqué la loi donc c'est quand même
singulier de nouveau replié
oui et donc est donc en ce qui concerne
les questions de contrôle au faciès bon
je reste ou droit de répondre à deux
questions mais je pense que la question
du certificat qui permettait de faire en
sorte que les mêmes ne soient pas
systématiquement contrôlés reste une
proposition qui est sur la table qui
faisait partie des engagements de
françois hollande
si c'est trop dur aux critiques et trop
compliqué comme l'a dit le premier
ministre dans ce cas il faut trouver
d'autres façons de procéder
quant à la question du droit de vote -
la question du droit de vote ne faut pas
se cacher à son petit doigt et on le
voit avec malheureusement la question
des langues régionales
s'il y a un veto aujourd'hui de la part
de la droite au sens large y compris des
centristes on sait bien qu'on ne peut
pas aboutir
donc il ya une nécessité pour réussir à
modifier la question du droit de vote
qu' on puisse passer au congrès qu'on y
ait un vote qui soient favorables et
donc les 3/5 aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
les réunir donc agité une promesse en
disant nous on est pour
mais c'est à cause des autres qu'on sait
pas faire on peut le faire c'est effet
politicienne globalement mais ça
entraîne aussi pour les gens le
sentiment qu'on soit un peu d'eux donc
moi je ne suis pas pour que on agite
tous les jours quelque chose ça reste
une revendication pour moi ce serait
quelque chose de légitime totalement
et puis c'est pas ce droit de vote mais
il faut bien constater qu'aujourd'hui
elle n'a pas les conditions politiques
pour l'atteindre alors on va passer à
autre chose à notre sujet le front de
l'emploi puisque lundi il y a une bonne
nouvelle le chômage a baissé au mois de
septembre est là mon magasin c'est la
plus forte baisse depuis huit ans au
mois de septembre la france a enregistré
23 mille 800 demandeurs d'emploi en
moins
un résultat encourageant pour la
ministre du travail
de quoi redonner le sourire aux députés
socialistes
les efforts ça paye toujours les efforts
des français et les efforts du
gouvernement
les efforts des français c'est ce qu'ils
ont consentis depuis à plusieurs années
pour redresser le pays à redresser ses
comptes publics les efforts du
gouvernement c'est sans relâche que ce
que nous faisons pour faire en sorte que
l'emploi redémarre mais l'opposition
dénonce elle une baisse du chômage en
trompe l'oeil
cette baisse est le dieu
elle est due essentiellement aussi aux
gens qui cherchaient du travail à temps
plein qui n'en cherche le plus à temps
plein parce qu'il voit bien que par
découragement ville il arrête on voit
aussi que le chômage des jeunes et c'est
tant mieux diminue mais c'est parce
qu'on injecte massivement des contrats
aidés
prudence aussi pour l'ailé gauche du ps
pour qui cette embellie ne valide pas la
stratégie du gouvernement
je la lis comme des phénomènes qui sont
principalement due à la baisse du prix
du pétrole est la baisse de l'euro qu'on
ait cette baisse qui est dure depuis un
moment
créer des conditions je dirais de rendre
plus plus attractif environnement
économique pour les entreprises
selon les prévisions nationales et
internationales le chômage devrait
diminuer en france l'année prochaine
reste à savoir s'il s'agira d'une baisse
nette ou plus d'une stabilisation alors
françois hollande a conditionné sa
candidature en 2017 à une baisse du
chômage est ce que vous pensez au vu
notamment de ces résultats que c'est
bien parti
à la fois pour l'emploi et pour françois
guillemin et donc je vais vous dire moi
ce que je constate c'est une bonne
nouvelle
infos comme de dire les choses quand il
ya moins de temps un résultat en trompe
l'oeil pour vous c'est quand même donc
ses résultats après que chacun analyse
les causes rigoriste dans différentes
c'est possible mais de fait c'est un
résultat je pense que on pourrait avoir
des résultats meilleurs nous c'est ce
que nous disons en tant qu'écologiste on
aurait pu faire en sorte que les la
politique qui a été mise en place
notamment le contrat d'impôts pour les
entreprises contre le 6 et donc aurait
pu être plus ciblés sur les secteurs les
plus créateurs d'emplois
je pense qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont
plus intensifs en emploi que d'autres
nous le disons notamment dans le cas de
la transition énergétique
quand on fait des énergies renouvelables
quand on fait de la réhabilitation
thermique des logements d'ailleurs
séparé les transports publics lire ils
vont pas je pense qu'on devrait plus
ciblée sur les secteurs les plus
intensifs en emploi puisque l'objectif
c'est bien de créer des emplois c'est
c'est pas de redonner des marges de
profit à toutes les entreprises quel que
soit l'objectif c'est de créer de
l'emploi c'est bien ça l'objectif est
d'ailleurs vous dites ce que c'est bien
ça le critère principal pour françois
hollande est donc à partie ce moment là
je pense que l'on devrait plus ciblée
sur les secteurs les plus actifs en
emploi mais que qui est déjà des
premiers résultats en tout état de cause
on peut s'en réjouir
ça fait d'ailleurs un certain temps que
notre pays crée plus d'emplois qu'ils
n'en détruisent simplement comme on a
une situation démographique qui est
défavorable puisqu'il ya plus de gens
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail
donc il faut il faut encore et qu'on
avait abusé la cour
pallois j'en sais rien c'est difficile
de savoir sur sur un point vous vous
êtes pas une courbe moi je suis un peu
mathieu de formation et les lieux à
temps et donc je sais qu'il faut
plusieurs points pour faire une courte
donc vous dire que la vie on a changé la
coupe c'est trop tôt trop tôt mais on va
passer au mardi l'assemblée qui examine
et qui continue à examiner le budget
l'assemblée qui a donc voté le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2016 de 186 voix contre 245
une majorité légèrement plus large qu'il
y a un an
à noter ce chiffre quand même 27 députés
se sont abstenus vais voter quoi pour
pour comme toutes les lois de finances
je fais partie d'un groupe c'est un peu
compliqué obama il ya pas d iliad il ya
des différences dans le groupe ça ne
vous a pas échappé
il a rejoint un des débats que nous
avions tout à leur savoir quel comment
on se situe en tant qu'écologiste par
rapport dans le rapport au pouvoir moi
je crois que on est plus utile quand on
est à l'intérieur ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire des compromis mais c'est
dommage pour un sujet aussi important
que la santé de la sécurité sociale qui
est des votes comme ça je vais pas vous
dire que c'est dommage que les gens
soient pas d'accord avec moi mais je
mets en même temps bon on fait ce
constat aujourd'hui est ce débat là et
n'est pas un débat négligeable sur
comment est ce qu'on pense que on pèse
le plus moi j'ai été maire adjoint de
paris pendant 11 ans j'ai voté forcément
des choses qui étaient là que j'ai
réalisé
et oui le budget le budget forcé le vote
mais en plus il ya des choses sur
lesquelles on n'est pas d'accord avec
nos partenaires c'est sinon c'est
touchant même parti mais il ya un
équilibre à dire que devraient à partir
des rapports de force qui sont sortis de
ce qu'ont dit les acteurs c'est ça la
démocratie
eh bien on obtient à 100 d'avancé qu'ils
sont les avancées qui sont utiles à
l'écologie tout en étant évidemment
solidaire de choses avec lesquelles on
est moins d'accord bon mais ça fait
partie des quelque chose que je n'arrive
pas à comprendre c'est les discussions
vous avec cécile duflot a nommé les
jours parce que c'est immoral qui tient
la tête de ceux qui ne veulent pas voter
ou qu'ils s'abstiennent dans votre
groupe
comment comment ce que vous arrivez à
discuter encore aujourd'hui comment vous
pouvez vous m messieurs alors que son
l'essentiel vous ne l'êtes pas non sur
beaucoup de choses on est d'accord sur
le fond on est d'accord par les accords
qu'il faut sortir du lot rôle essentiel
on n'est pas forcément d'accord sur les
actes définitifs à la fin sur qu'est-ce
qu'on vote passe
fait à la fin on sait ce budget va
passer donc ça ne dépend pas de notre
vote donc la question est de savoir donc
comme dans quelle stratégie on s'inscrit
nous sommes un certain nombre à penser
qu'on doit s'inscrire dans une majorité
parce que à partir le monde sait ce que
d'une majorité on pourra obtenir de nos
partenaires des avancées sur des sujets
qui nous importe en tant qu'écologiste y
en a d'autres qui pensent que
globalement ils sont trop en dea
correction gouvernement pour leur faire
sur le cadeau qui pourrait estime être
un cadeau de voter pour voilà c'est une
différence de stratégie
cliquez pas comme ça comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure on est dans notre
histoire
cette question on est un mouvement jeune
par rapport à toutes les autres
formations politiques
les écologistes à un mouvement jeune il
ça fait qu'on attend presque presque 40
ans un des atouts que l'écologie existe
mais ça regardez le mouvement ouvrier le
temps qu'il lui a fallu pour ceux
construits et ses faibles et donc d'y
arriver
vous n'allez pas pouvoir vous un mais je
ne vous dis pas que tout ça est simple
et je préférerais qu'on compte qu'on
arrive à grandir plus vite mais dans la
question du rapport au pouvoir les
écologistes ont progressé sur le pouvoir
local le pouvoir régional
c'est aujourd'hui accepter de matinée au
niveau national pour l'instant il n'y a
pas une maturité suffisante pour que
l'ensemble de la famille se mettent
d'accord dans quelles conditions on
gouverne et donc ça se fait de face à
cette façon un peu en occultant donc on
avait bien compris la participation on
l'a vu à un moment oui on avait bien
construites ou tapez 2 pour aller au
gouvernement
dire qu'on avait préparé un accord c'est
ainsi pour une négociation etc et donc
ça s'est bien passé et puis d'un coup il
ya eu une rupture
cette rupture n'a pas été discutée
collectivement elle a été mal vécue elle
elle continue à diviser profondément s
quinze jours on va réussir à retrouver
un chemin ensemble et se comprendre sur
c'est quoi les conditions collective
moi je l'espère parce que la famille
écologiste peut avancer plus mais enfin
bon si si on n'y arrive pas il existe un
parti socialiste est un parti communiste
au sein de ce qui s'appelait autrefois
le mouvement ouvrier et donc lavées
d'aller voir s'il peut ou non c'est vrai
ça que je dis mais il peut exister
pendant un certain temps un parti
écologiste plus protestataire est un
parti écologiste plus sincères en soit
françois transformateurs à cliquer là je
ne sais pas si je ne sais pas comment
l'histoire s'écrit la même façon vous
avez la cfdt et la cgt chez les
syndicats vous avez des niveaux de
participation aux responsabilités qui
sont pas les mêmes et on voit par
exemple attendant de voir la suite de
l'histoire voilà on revient aux affaires
parlementaires députés et sénateurs ont
échoué à trouver une version commune sur
le projet de loi santé qui instaure
notamment le tiers payant généralisé
retour donc à l'assemblée nationale pour
une nouvelle lecture explications mounir
ce aussi une heure de discussion a suffi
pour acter le désaccord est l'échec de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi santé
l'issue était prévisible au cours de son
examen au sénat le texte avait été vidé
de ses mesures-phare par la majorité de
droite
je pense qu'à l'assemblée nationale
madame la ministre va souhaiter en effet
remettre ces marqueurs ce qu'elle
appelle ses marqueurs forts du texte est
justement sur lesquels nous sommes
opposés sur lesquels les professions de
santé sont surtout très remonté puis
s'il ya une unanimité des des syndicats
médicaux contre contre le projet de loi
le projet doit pousser de nombreuses
corporations dans la rue les médecins
libéraux avaient manifesté pour dénoncer
ce texte et notamment la mise en place
du tiers payant généralisé une promesse
de campagne de françois hollande
les buralistes s'étaient insurgés contre
l'instauration du paquet de cigarettes
neutre et pour le gouvernement ces deux
mesures sont centrales un certain nombre
de divergences mais les deux principales
c'est évidemment ce sont le paquet
neutre est ce sont la généralisation du
tiers payant est ça c'était des points
j'allais dire presque de non retour qui
ont fait qu'il n'y a pas eu d'accord sur
la cmp à partir du 16 novembre le texte
va revenir à l'assemblée nationale la
ministre de la santé espère que son
projet de loi sera adopté avant la fin
de l'année 2015 artir payant obligatoire
paquets de cigarettes neutres c'est
quand même deux mesures très importantes
de santé publique n'y a pas d'accord
entre députés et sénateurs penser que le
gouvernement a raison d'aller bien sûr
jusqu'au bout malgré la très forte
opposition et notamment des médecins
pour qu'ils continuent à discuter à
avancer sur les mesures mais enfin quand
il ya des mesures comme celles là qui
sont des mesures sociales positives ou
des mesures de santé
le paquet de cigarettes neutre mais
aussi à des mesures dans cette loi sur
la santé environnementale qui sont
importantes il faut qu'on aille au bout
on a été élu pour ça
l'adisq et cette stratégie quand on a
comme ça toute une profession alors ça
veut dire que voudrait rien changer et
rester dans l'immobilisme et ne pas
avancer alors de la demande
la demande aujourd'hui la société c'est
quand même con on est on est une santé
qui soit plus accessible pour tous donc
non moi je pense que il ya un moment où
il ya du rapport de force parfois dans
la société c'est mais il faut assumer
son rôle c'est nous qui avons été élus
qu'ils vont rendre des comptes et si on
veut plus nous on nous vire à mai mais
de fait sûr sûr sûr sûr ces mandats sur
lesquels on est élu on doit on doit on
doit avancer assumer le rôle de
représentativité de la société ne vaut
pas autre texte que les sénateurs ont
rejeté
c'est le projet de loi de ratification
des chartes sur les langues régionales
une question préalable voté par la
droite et une majorité des radicaux a
entraîné le rejet du texte
manuel valls lui est venu dire aux
sénateurs ce qu'il en pensait et goûter
vous réagissez justin je déplore ce
choix et je leur dis très sincèrement je
crois que ce choix est une erreur une
erreur politique
car pour masquer vos propres divisions
sur cette question là c'est des choses
qui arrivent
vous avez utilisé un artifice de
procédure
vous n'êtes pas les premiers vous ne
serez pas les derniers une erreur qu'à
vous majorité sénatoriale vous avez
refusé par ailleurs et avec parfois
quelques contradictions avec ce qu'on
peut entendre à quelques semaines du
rendez vous des régionales d'entendre
les territoires que vous représentez une
république forte monsieur le sénateur
c'est une république une et indivisible
pas une république
enfermé dans une conception étroite ra
boury de son unité pas une république au
coeur sec qui chasse de son patrimoine
national
tous ces imaginaires sans laquelle la
langue française
notre culture ne serait pas aussi belle
et elle est loin le prémunissent vision
rabougrie de la république à tignes mais
je suis complètement d'accord enfin de
fait nous défendons nous en tant
qu'écologiste depuis très longtemps la
reconnaissance des langues régionales on
est seul pays de l'union européenne
avoir une seule langue qu'ils soient
reconnus tout autre pays reconnaissent
plusieurs langues sur leur territoire à
dire parce que ça fait partie de la
diversité la langue française restera la
langue de l'unité sur le sur l'ensemble
du territoire
mais reconnaître la capacité à pour ses
autres langues régionales à pouvoir
exister c'était tout un balcon moment de
faire ce débat
les actionnaires ne sait jamais le bon
encontre quand les gens ne veulent pas
mon cas il ya un moment
la question n'est pas de savoir si on
fait de la tactique politicienne ou si
on pense aussi on est on a des
convictions et qu'on les porte
il y avait un vrai débat d'idées j'ai
compté public identité oui oui j'ai un
vrai débat d'idées à l'assemblée
nationale aussi mais dans d'ossun au
sein du vote qui a eu à l'assemblée
nationale il y avait pas mal de députés
de l'ump qui ont voté pour cette de
cette modification à la ratification de
la langue des chartes de la radio dans
la charte des langues
parmi les détracteurs de cette charte
certains disent actes et la
reconnaissance des langues régionales
c'est faire un pas vers le
communautarisme n'importe quoi à
n'importe quoi franchement franchement
le pourrai ce que donc l'ensemble les
autres pays de l'union européenne qui
reconnaissent les langues régionales
sont que des pays communautariste est ce
que cette charte donc qui était une
charte de l'onu est une charte
communautariste nom et un moment on peut
avoir une série leur titre i 14h10
peut-être reprenez-vous si vraiment
c'est une question purement
politiciennes parce que les élections
régionales et que ça les gêne et de le
voter maintenant peut-être de revoir un
peu leur copie d'ici
d'ici quelques temps pour qu'on puisse
éventuellement repasser ce sujet parce
que jean-louis dans le monde et ils
pouvoir faire cette avancée dit qu'ils
seraient quelque chose qui serait une
reconnaissance ça n'enlève rien à
personne
ça n'enlève rien à personne c'est juste
un droit supplémentaire pour ceux qui
ont envie de se reconnaître dans leur
look leur origine aux traditions leur
leur culture est d'être un on est on est
chacun un ensemble de culture on enlève
pas mais moi c'est un droit
supplémentaire
oui mois passés au mercredi encore lui
le premier ministre est invité il est
partout les invités du bondy blog
et au cours de cette interview le
premier ministre a fait une déclaration
tout devra être fait pour empêcher des
victoires du front national aux
régionales voilà une phrase qui a
déclenché une avalanche de réactions
politiques on voit tout cela avec jean
baptiste daoulas un front national au
plus haut dans les sondages et manuel
valls relance le débat sur le front
républicain il est hors de question de
laisser le front national gagner une
région donc tout devra être fait pour
l'empêcher
je vous donne tout devra être fait pour
l'empêcher donc je vous donne rendez
vous le soir du premier tour en
septembre pourtant jean christophe
cambadélis estimait que les positions
extrémistes de xavier bertrand et
christian estrosi empêchait tout front
républicain
ce matin le patron du ps est beaucoup
moins catégorique je n'exclus rien mais
ma pensée première et pour gagner le
premier tour un front républicain
ressuscité mais avec qui à la gauche de
la gauche jean luc mélenchon ne veut pas
en entendre parler
j'estime que c'est mélanger les torchons
et serviettes et de violer le vote des
gens quant aux républicains
ils ne veulent ni fusion ni désistement
avec le ps quoi que fasse le parti
socialiste ce n'est pas notre problème
nous ne leur demandons rien en aucun cas
nos candidats ne prendront langue avec
le parti socialiste
mais pour compliquer encore un peu les
choses le modem et lui dit
alliés aux républicains pour les
régionales plaide pour le front
républicain
si on identifie un risque mortel alors
on s'engage et il revient aux
responsables des courants différents du
pays de dire que au deuxième tour il
faut voter pour celui qui pourra faire
barrage au front national comme nous
l'avons fait au moment des élections
départementales
on se positionnera entre guillemets
département par département c'était le
cas à l'époque région par région
demain à un mois du premier tour des
régionales la stratégie des partis
républicain face au fn reste flou de
quoi déstabiliser encore un peu plus
leurs électeurs tout doit être fait a
dit le premier ministre
est ce que ça veut dire si on prend un
exemple très concret sandrine rousseau
qui est candidate europe ecologie les
verts dans le nord de la france doit
elle retiré sa candidature par exemple
il reste quelques jours encore moi j'ai
toujours plaidé dans ces deux régions
nord pas de calais picardie et paccard
haut des listes communes de gauche des
premiers tours donc j'ai pas changé
d'avis donc si on peut encore réussir à
faire l'union dès le premier tour
j'en serai très heureux et très longue
où c'est possible ou pas si les gens si
les gens ont envie de le faire il ya
toutes les possibilités pour le faire je
pense que il ya un besoin face au front
national ces on est face à un danger non
pas seulement pour nos convictions mais
pour le fonctionnement de la république
je pense qu'il faut il faut bloquer la
capacité du front national à monter en
puissance et donc éviter en effet qu'ils
prennent la tête des régions mais je
veux signaler quand même que l'on voit
bien dans toute cette histoire ou où les
électeurs ne pas comprendre grand chose
que finalement tout ça n'arrive que
parce que on a des règles du jeu
particulièrement compliqué de dire qu'on
a une soi-disant proportionnelle mais
avec une prime pour la liste arrive au
second tour si on a vu une
proportionnelle simple à un tour on
aurait les assemblées qui serait élu en
proportion on n'aurait pas besoin de se
poser la question est ce qu'on fusionne
nos listes ensemble et c'est entre les
deux tours pouvoir avant le premier tour
comme je le suggérais à l'instant et
simplement délire bord de deux scooters
et le mode de scrutin qu'on a eu pendant
un certain temps pour les élections qui
étaient purement proportionnelle
pourquoi il a été changé à cause déjà du
front national parce qu'une partie des
électeurs pas partie des élus plutôt de
l'ump s'était allié avec le front
national pour prendre d'élan au changeur
connaître à gauche mais je pense que
finalement on se prononcer un peu mis
les pieds dans le tapis dès aujourd'hui
on peut permettre éventuellement à
marine le pen avec 34% des voix aussi
c est ce qui est à dire un peu plus d'un
tiers des voix de prendre la prime est
de devenir d'avoir de l'ensemble du
pouvoir et donc alors que si on avait un
mode de scrutin proportionnel quelqu'un
qui a 30 4% des votes à 31 1 % des
sièges et donc une fois que tu as trouvé
oui on pourrait se retrouver pour
l'instant c'est comme ça donc les
candidats en question s'ils se
maintiennent vous
eric ils devront assumer prendre leur
responsabilité en cas de en cas de
victoire du front national je pense je
pense je pense que en effet si jamais le
front national gagne dans certaines
régions ceux qui auront pensé qu'il
pouvait continuer à faire de la
politique comme d'habitude pour trop une
responsabilité oui oui mais moi moi je
devrais je suis je suis inquiet je sur
le fait qu' on considère que finalement
bon vaches vers chacun ses petites
listes cécile grappillé ensemble de
voies pour essayer dans des fusions
compliqué et cetera de pouvoir
éventuellement que la liste de gauche
passent devant celles de droite etc
sauf que si cette façon c'est le front
national qui est au dessus c'est le
front national qui gagnera donc là là
cette histoire de tambouille ne prend
pas en compte le fait que on est passé
dans un monde tripolaire quelque part
dans calcul vous dites faut penser oui
c'était gaïa il ya un tel danger il ya
une telle responsabilité face aux
croisiens que l'on doive changer l'âge
aura des leçons à tirer au vue de 2017 à
base on est on est dans le même cas de
figure c'est à dire d'un mode d'un mode
de fonctionnement la présidentielle où
on l'a conçu pour un monde bipolaire et
donc vous n'avez que deux candidats
qualifiés au second tour
bon on va pas changer l'élection
présidentielle d'ici l'élection de 2017
mais donc ça veut dire que quand vous
avez trois forces de forcer à peu près
équivalente
ben c'est le troisième qui se fait
éliminer bon et donc ça peut être à
quelques centaines de milliers quelques
dizaines de milliers de voix
éventuellement éliminer donc la question
de savoir comment dès le premier tour
vous êtes obligé de vous rassembler se
pose et on veut dire pas de candidat
vert moi je dis moi moi j'ai défendu le
fait que les écologistes et un candidat
élections présidentielles
systématiquement depuis toujours parce
que c'est une élection structurants
sauf que cette fois ci en effet la
question se pose différemment avec le
fait que pour la première fois on sait
que le front national à une très forte
probabilité d'être de mauvais à cécile
duflot de ne pas s'engager jeudi
la question doit être posée mais ça ne
veut pas dire systématiquement qu' on
doit forcément s'effacer s'il n'y a pas
d'autre candidat qui peut représenter
l'écologie abandonné dans un message
clair aussi
oui mais ça va se construire il faut il
faut il faut un temps pour le construire
mais si la question qui est posée c'est
par exemple de soutenir françois
hollande qui si dans le cas où il serait
candidat
dès le premier tour d'élection
présidentielle pour qu' il puisse y
avoir cette possibilité là encore
faut-il que non seulement les appareils
écologistes mais surtout les électeurs
écologistes
puisse avoir envie de voter pour lui
donc ça dépendra de son bilan en terme
d'écologie et de son projet dans son
bilan par exemple il ya une promesse
assez emblématique qui s'appelle la
fermeture de fessenheim dans le
quinquennat
et bien aujourd'hui les conditions sont
réunies pour pouvoir fermer fessenheim
qui l'avait d'un point de vue technique
je veux non seulement un engagement mais
je veux une fermeture d'un quinquennat
c'est peu dire pas de fermeture eh ben
ça ça ça remet en question la capacité
de françois hollande à pouvoir
convaincre ses électeurs des collèges en
idées pas dans dans le oui oui et non
aujourd'hui à un an et demi de
l'élection
la question aujourd'hui c'est je pense
que son intérêt à lui s'il veut pouvoir
à l'élection présidentielle et
convaincre les électeurs écologistes
c'est d'avoir tenu son engagement
puisqu'il est possible de le tenir
il faut le il faut tenir et va fermer
fessenheim en 2016 en parlant d'
d'engagement ça me permettent de faire
la transition et à la présidence de
france télévisions qui a été auditionnée
par les députés et qui a donc pris un
engagement devant la représentation
nationale et côté je m'engage à ce qu'on
soit à déficit zéro en 2016 je ne
lâcherai rien sur le plan d'économies
mais en parallèle il faut aussi bien
entendu qu'on lance dès à présent des
réformes de structure on a enchaîné des
plans de départs en retraite
on est aujourd'hui dans un plan de
départs volontaires je crois qu'on ne
peut pas considérer que cette entreprise
puisse retrouver son énergie retrouver
un élan vital retrouver une envie d'être
plus efficace d'être plus productif si
on enchaîne comme cela les plans de
départs question très rapide le
gouvernement a refusé le retour de la
publicité l'augmentation de la redevance
est ce que c'est une erreur
je vais vraiment pas spécialiste sur ces
questions où je reconnais volontiers
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas une vision claire
de ce qu'il faudrait faire en la matière
remettre la publicité je pense pas ou ne
fait on s'est habitué et tant mieux
avoir moins de publicité mais trouver
des recettes supplémentaires pour france
télévisions puisse fonctionner ça me
paraît important alors on va revenir
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée lors des
questions d'actualité henri guaino s'en
est pris à la justice l'ancien
conseiller de sarkozy condamné la
semaine dernière pour outrage à
magistrat a profité de la séance de
questions pour interpeller le
gouvernement à écouter truction à charge
mise en examen justifiable mépris de la
constitution mépris de la loi
mépris des victimes abus de pouvoir
voilà le visage une juste
ce qu'ils méritent plus en ans dans la
magistrature comme partout ailleurs il y
a des gens qui honorent leurs fonctions
il ya aussi des pervers des psycho pas
des militants aveuglés par leur
idéologie question qui s'adresse aussi
aux vice présidents de l'assemblée
nationale et ce que le député henri
guaino est sorti de son rôle
écoutez je sais pas s'il faut qualifié
de pervers ou le psychopathe ou six
enfin c'est ce genre de qualificatif on
pourrait l'utiliser il dit des
magistrats on pourrait dire aussi à des
élus etc
je te ferai trappe un peu à la hauteur
de leur rôle je veux dire qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire cette
provocation qu'il fait c'est vraiment de
la provoc jamais de la république
prononcé pas digne et puis d'ailleurs il
n'y a pas eu un élu républicain qui
l'applaudît ils ont tous regarder leurs
godasses dirige était très gênée par
cette offensive qui est juste lié à un
règlement de comptes parce qu'il n'est
pas content d'une décision de justice le
concernant enfin c'est incroyable plus
deux jours après qu'est-ce qu'il nous
explique c'est qu'ils ont plus il
pourrait travailler avec marion
maréchal-le pen donc on est on est sur
un sur sur un élu qui est en train de
dériver complètement dans quelque chose
qui n'est pas n'est pas l'image qu'on
pouvait avoir d'henri guaino quels que
soient les désaccords qui était plutôt
un élu je manque qu'elle attachait les
duels riddick je pense que en tout cas
je sais pas qu'est ce qui les rend de
quoi quoi il est en recherche mais
c'était très choquant enfin sur le
moment on sait tout le monde tout le
monde se disait mais jusqu'où il va
aller dans cette truc qui est en plus un
truc qu'il avait lu pas écrit je dirais
donc il lisait un papier avec cette
volonté visiblement d'en découdre avec
la ministre
juste pour régler un compte personnel
enfin sais c'est pas à la hauteur
franchement au passo jeudi nicolas
sarkozy lui est à moscou
voilà une visite qui a fait du bruit au
france diplomatie parallèle selon
certains manuels valls a mis en garde
l'ancien président de la république
garde françois hollande et vladimir
poutine début octobre des rapports froid
et de nombreux désaccords
nicolas sarkozy avec le même l'a dit
mercredi et jeudi soir sourire et
tutoiement l'ancien président de la
république lui formule le souhait d'un
retour de la russie sur la scène
internationale j'ai dit à monsieur
bookeen que je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi on exclut la russie du g8
justement parce qu'il ya des désaccords
il faut deux pattes davantage parler une
position contraire la diplomatie
française qui s'opposent encore à la
russie sur le dossier syrien
une attitude contre-productive d'après
le premier ministre
nicolas sarkozy l'ancien président de la
république il rencontre qui il veut mais
moi ce que je souhaite d'une manière
générale c'est que l'opposition comme la
majorité sur les questions de politique
étrangère sur les questions de défense
comme le souhaitent les français nous
retrouvions sur l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
en l'occurence une politique une vision
commune de ce qui se passe en syrie
c'est ce que je demande aux leaders de
l'opposition qui ne met pas en cause ce
qui est aujourd'hui engagé une demande
que nicolas sarkozy balaie d'un revers
de main je ne veux pas polémiquer avec
monsieur valls on a parlé monsieur
poutine deux choses tellement plus
importante que la petite politique
ailleurs et d'ajouter qu'il lui paraît
normal de parler en tant que président
de l'opposition avec les chefs des temps
katia va vous poser la question sur
nicolas sarkozy et ce voyage vous
présente jarrassé notre partenaire du
scanner du figaro qui va vous
interviewer dans quelques secondes
alors nicolas sarkozy et vladimir
poutine se connaissent assez bien
peut-être mieux que ne se connaissent
françois hollande est le diable est ce
que ça peut pas avoir du bon quand même
ce type de rencontre ça peut avoir du
bon pour les relations et franchement ça
m'arrivait quelque chose mais ça m'a
rappelé georges marchais en 1981 allant
à moscou et disant que l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par l'union soviétique
finalement c'était bien et un côté je
vais à moscou et puis jeudi du bien des
leaders à moscou je trouve que quelque
part c'est pas c'est pas vraiment aimer
vraiment pas à la hauteur de ce que doit
être le rôle d'un ancien président de la
république donc c'est de la diplomatie
parallèle
la prouesse de la volonté d'essayer de
se positionner sur le champ politique
national mais en utilisant
l'international et finalement en allant
cautionner cette chose-là diplomatiques
délicats ya quand même des problèmes
avec l'union avec avec la russie
aujourd'hui je dirais la question
ukraine de la crimée la question de la
syrie etc
donc est ce que est ce qu'on peut se
permettre comme ça d'aller voir un chef
d'état est de 10 robin il ya le
président en exercice mais moi l'ancien
président qu'aspire à leur devenir
finalement je vais mener une autre
politique par rapport à la russie
tout ça tout ça n'est pas n'est pas à la
hauteur aujourd'hui de ce que devrait
être une capacité dans un pays qui a une
responsabilité aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs rues
nicholas sparks n'a pas été à la hauteur
oui je pense en effet c'est quelque
chose qui n'est qu'ils cherchent à
essayer de se positionner par rapport à
des enjeux politiques internes français
basile de la nation plutôt de
l'assurance sur la primaire interne oui
oui exactement oui je pense que c'est
pas digne ans après dans la république
parce que de fait quand on a été présent
dans le public quand on aspire en plus à
le redevenir je veux dire qu'on doit
avoir une vision quelque part de ce que
sont des questions on est conduite sur
des questions de guéret t1 10 ans qui
sont qui sont importants qu'il s'agisse
du proche orient ou qu'il s'agisse de
l'ukraine sur lesquels on peut pas juste
tout d'un coup dira pas le contraire de
ce que le chef de l'état qui est quand
même été élu par les français il ya un
moment aussi
si on est républicain si on acceptait
qui ont des démocrates et qu'on accepte
le résultat des élections
bon bah il ya il y en a qui sont en
fonction pendant cinq ans on peut être
en désaccord aller sur place faire le
petit télégraphiste pour dire finalement
le coucou moi je suis le représentant de
poutine
le plus de celui qui est le plus proche
en compétition avec marine le pen et
c'est à qui elle aussi peut être proche
de poutine et puis aussi mélenchon qui
était un pas de tir c'est très bizarre
moi je trouve très bizarre aujourd'hui
cette surenchère qu'il peut y avoir
c'est un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont des acteurs politiques en france
à vouloir être les plus proches de
poutine on va passer à la loupe du scan
jim est avec nous jim c'est à vous
j'aimerais qu'on reparle avec vous denis
baupin de l'ambiance au sein du groupe
écologiste à la sonde et vous en avez
parlé un peu tout à l'heure vous avez
dit dans un bel euphémisme
on n'est pas toujours forcément d'accord
alors y en a au groupe écolo qui est
beaucoup plus direct c'est françois de
rugy qui dit c'est une guérilla
permanente
est-ce que vous iriez jusque-là non mais
ça dépend sur quoi on va dire que sur
sur le fond des sujets moi je suis très
étonné dans nos réunions groupe sur le
fond des sujets quand on débat sur la
question des énergies contre ce débat
sur la question des réfugiés et c'est le
ballon on a une philosophie commune ce
pas par hasard si on école existe et
qu'on travaille depuis des années mais
c'est vrai que après cette question de
la stratégie à savoir le vis-à-vis du
gouvernement fait que ans après ça
entraîne des billets sur la façon de
présenter les choses et donc dans ce
cadre là c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup on
retrouve souvent des désaccords entre
nourris et ses visions de plus des
accords sur la stratégie à mener que
vraiment sur le fond
en tout cas des convictions
fondeur est ce que est ce que vous
n'avez pas été déçus finalement un peu
par cécile duflot qui aurait peut-être
privilégier ses intérêts personnels aux
intérêts du parti en se rapprochant un
moment de jean luc mélenchon en parlant
de la présidentielle est ce que est ce
que ça a été son rôle ce qu'elle vous a
pas un peu déçu j'ai été déçu quand
cécile duflot est sorti gouvernement va
pas vous le cacher nous dira je la
trouvais très bonne mini-jeux la
soutenait à fond comme ministre avait
soutenu comme secrétaire nationale pour
qu'on fasse l'accord avec les partis
socialistes pour qu'on arrive aux
responsabilités et je pense que la
sortie du gouvernement a été une très
grosse erreur je veux dire qu'il nous a
privés de beaucoup de capacités de le
lier dire à l'époque qui lui a été
proposé d'être ministre de l'écologie et
de l'énergie dans une période où on
était en préparation d'une loi sur la
transition énergétique on allait
accueillir la conférence climatique qui
a lieu dans quelques semaines dans une
période où on a nommé un nouveau
président à edf un nouveau président
agit des fraises en tout cas le futur
qui sera nommé le nouveau patron d'areva
le nouveau prêtre ont dû se voir pas
dire la capacité des écologistes a pesé
à ce moment là sur les politiques
énergétiques dans le pays le plus
nucléarisé du monde c'est quelque chose
pour moi en tout cas en terme de
conviction et des très importants et
donc sortir comme ça si je pense que
c'est une erreur
il ya en effet au sénat c'est compliqué
aussi puisque jean vincent placé est
menacée d'une fronde
on sait que le groupe est composé de 10
parlementaires écologistes soit le
minimum requis pour qu'ils puissent
survivre c'est à dire que si on a un qui
part le groupe est mort est ce que c'est
une hypothèse crédible il faut qu'ils se
mettent d'accord
je pense qu'on a réussi à se mettre
d'accord à l'assemblée nationale sur un
mode de fonctionnement qui est chaotique
m'enfin vous utilisez aller regarder
comment on fonctionne d'autres groupes
comme le groupe socialiste comme l'euro
près républicain et cetera il ya des
divergences à l'intérieur mais il trouve
un mode de fonctionnement mais voilà il
faut qu'en changeant de président m non
je ne vais pas m'ingérer dans le dans la
question du des sénateurs parce que j'ai
mon avis mais c'est pas à moi d'aller
dire ici ce que je pense sur la façon de
s organiser
c'est à eux de le faire la même façon
que je n'aurais pas accepté que les
sénateurs nous disent à nous je
conseille peut-être vu non non c'est
rigolo et audel et transformer le donner
dix en un conseil général pour que
j'essaie de dire la mère de sarah
parlons toujours du jour - sont placés
il vient d'obtenir une place sur la
liste de claude bartolone dans l'essonne
pour les régionales de france stéphane
gatignon aussi qui a quitté europe
écologie sera sur cinquième de liste en
seine saint denis ça vous agace pas un
peu de voir ses anciens écolo qui vont
du coup se retrouver opposés à la liste
des manuels cos au premier tour c'est
bon comment vous je suis je suis en
désaccord avec eux sur le fait d'avoir
choisi cette stratégie ils le savent
voilà sur le fait que je pense que
quelles que soient nos désaccords sur la
politique nationale
ça ne justifiait pas que dans la région
ile de france on se divise
à partir du moment où on dans la région
ile de france europe écologie les verts
avaient choisi l'autonomie par rapport
au fond de gauche parce qu'ils étaient
quand même l'un des critères sur lequel
il y avait un désaccord entre leur
vincent et d'autre et
europe-écologie-verts voilà ils ont fait
leur choix maintenant ces listes sont
déposées jaillira toute façon un
bulletin de vote écologiste aux
élections régionales sur les tables
lorsque les électeurs ayant voté le 6
décembre ce sera le bulletin de vote et
malcoste dernière question très
rapidement philippe verdier qui est le
monsieur météo de france 2 qui auteur à
rompsay d'un livre qui remet en cause le
consensus scientifique autour du
réchauffement climatique il a été
convoqué cette semaine par sa direction
ses visions pour un entretien préalable
à licenciement est ce qu'il faut en
aller jusque là franchement c'est pas
moi - d'occuper de la france télévisions
on est le rtf c'est fini donc de fait
par contre je pense que les
climatosceptiques comme on les appelle
et à l'aide de catégorie en fait est une
catégorie c ceux qui sont payés par les
lobbys et le bij pétroliers du charbon
et caetera et donc qu'ils utilisent leur
statut pour défendre quelque chose d'
indéfendables c'est à dire que le
changement climatique n'existerait pas
et puis il ya des gens qui cherchent à
se faire une notoriété moi ce monsieur
je connaissais pas son existence jusqu'à
temps qu'il devienne un clown ne
réduiront pas pas forcément obligatoire
quoi c'est pas moi c'est assez passé
franchement pas à moi dont des idées on
assez de choses à dire et qui sont de
notre responsabilité
sans aller nous
à la place de la présidence de france
télévisions gym pour cette analyse on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine et
nous on termine avec un sujet pour vous
denis baupin
le diesel les 28 may européens ont voté
l'assouplissement des taux de pollution
pour les moteurs diesel
écoutez la réaction de ségolène royal la
ministre c'est insuffisant
c'est même très insultant mais c'est une
première étape c'est à dire que le point
positif c'est que les contrôles des
véhicules seront faits en circulation
réelle c'est-à-dire seront de vrais
contrôles
oui ça c'était donc la réaction ségolène
royal sur les contrôles des véhicules
l'union européenne denis baupin
s'est-elle mise à genoux devant le lobby
automobile
je suis je suis je suis inquiet sur la
décision qui a été prise par l'union
européenne par un comité ad-hoc et dont
père dont dont on ne connaît même pas la
composition comme lé titre d oui mais
justement mais est donc ce qu'a dit
ségolène royal et je pense qu'elle a
raison c'est que les ministres doivent
se ressaisir du sujet dire que c'est aux
politiques ceux qui rendent des comptes
ceux qui sont élus de prendre les
décisions
aujourd'hui ce elle a raison de dire que
le dispositif qui est prévu
d'homologation et mieux que celui qui
est en vigueur aujourd'hui dans tout le
monde sait que il est truqué par tout le
monde tous les consommateurs mais a
comme aimer mais de prison mais de fait
passer passer d'un mécanisme à l'autre
n'autorise pas pour autant à changer la
façon dont on va calculer et c'est ça
qui pose problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
au travers de la décision qui a été
prise cette semaine on donne le
sentiment que l'on va autoriser les
constructeurs automobiles à polluer plus
que ce qu'on va dire au consommateur
évidemment non il faut revenir cette
décision il faut que les consommateurs
puissent avoir confiance dans ce qu on
leur dira et donc que les tests soient
réellement des tests qui permettent de
mesurer la réalité vers l'été police le
mot de la fin merci denis baupin merci à
tous pour se retrouver la semaine
prochaine